what is the NBA all-star weekend mean to
you it's mostly a lot of fun right we we
do a lot of work most weekends but this
is a fun one because a lot of friends
come together it's mostly about slam
dunks and skills contest and the best
players in the game getting out there
and playing a lot of offense so given
how popular this weekend is the
personalities the events those who say
sports television live sports is in a
bubble it's gonna burst it just costs
too much they're crazy off if they're
wrong I want to characterize their
mental state but I would suggest that
their judgment is wrong sports rights
continue to appreciate we're invested in
the long-term value of live sports we
had last year one of our best rating
years in the history of our company and
I think it speaks to the value of live
rights in this environment I've got my
phone with me my tablet is in the bag
how do you watch this stuff how many
screens to you well we actually have we
produce about four or five hours per
hour so actually just sitting here
nation is more than 24 hours ago yeah we
produce many more hours than there are
hours of the day so I'm consistently
falling behind what I can watch and by
that's why you can watch it in your
smartphone you can watch them your
tablet it so that people can watch
sports whenever they would like to
that's the must now give it to them how
they want it where they want it when
they work particular since is live right
you're gonna watch the game and you're
here to text some of your dinner party
or you're you know in a business meeting
and you want to slip down and see what
the score is we catch a highlight we
want to make sure you can get that and
how do you maintain your position your
edge seeing that there are more and more
platforms offering sports well we're
going to maintain our position edge by
the aggregation of sports right we have
rights we have continuing to present
them to fans wherever they want to get
them whenever they want to get them
adopting technology so that when new
things come along they're still branded
ESPN partnering with partnering with
social media companies and technology
companies to make sure the only people
watch sports on Facebook they're
watching on ESPN video player when they
go to snapchat and look at sports
content they're looking on the new
discovery platform at ESPN content that
that's kind of how we think about that
everybody thinks the bubble the folks
who know about these things tell me
where we're headed
is individualized advertisement they
will know whether because if your
partner with Facebook or Twitter they'll
know who's watching don't know when
they're watching they know what they
want then it would go by so that would
suggest that there's still lots more
money out there should be associated the
sports world look we think that one the
fact that it's live and you can
aggregate the audience where most
audiences are now at your gate over
three days or seven days or 30 days
makes it valuable for advertising
clearly more data and rich data will
make it more more valuable for
advertisers and we have an opportunity
to do that because fans identify their
favorite teams they identify their
fantasy players so that we can know
enough things we can identify geography
age in order to help advertisers reach
their targets more precisely given all
this rich data you have now who should
you be targeting next what demographic
isn't tuning in that you want to go
after well we're after every demographic
we did just announced yesterday a new
website that will be about race politics
and sports called the undefeated with
Jason Whitlock because that African
American audience is very important to
us we have our W initiative because the
female sports audience is very important
to us you know that we've been engaged
in a high priority for us hispanic fans
to watch sports and watch ESPN we want
to serve all fans we are we're not
anxious to exclude anybody and you
wouldn't got the world cup of hockey
after letting the NHL's oh it seems as
if in basketball parlance maybe this is
an aggressive four corners you're
aggressively acquiring but then you're
keeping everybody else out you want all
the live rights because you know that's
where they nipples we believe in the
value of life rice you know you're using
basketball parlance you don't basketball
part you guys are double teaming me here
I'm gonna see if I handle is here for a
few more minutes and get get about
height advantage I think you're you're
right I do have a high dat face im gonna
shoot over you i post her up may go off
the dribble huh how about team
valuations we talk about meteorites we
got the nets for sale we've seen see
Ballmer just step in in California do
you think there's a bubble there no I
don't think there's a bubble there look
there sigh it's like suggesting that
there's a bubble for Vermeer paintings
or real estate Malibu right there's very
limited supply the indoor honor the envy
the NFL Major League Baseball are the
best most exclusive clubs in the world I
mean people want to do to be in those
clubs so the value of those clubs are
going to continue to appreciate how you
ask david levy what do you want and he
said i want the NFL and the value
proposition there is still high people
say oh you had all the off-field tarnish
nothing sticks did anything stick was
there any effect to the NFL and its
partners I look I think that they
rightly are quite concerned about making
sure they handle these issues protect
the shield and I think they're in the
process of doing that night Rodgers made
the moves with new hires and new
initiatives to do that so yeah I don't
think anybody takes those things lightly
I do think most fans separate the game
on the field and the off-field issues
and the off-field issues to your point
have not affected how they like the game
on the field or on the screen you know
what I also love they love betting on
the stuff let's be honest they love to
bet and fantasy mm-hmm ESPN has said it
will get involved in some way daily
fantasy and we know adam silver is now
proposing that Congress legalize sports
get how do you benefit look we benefit
anytime there is increased interest in
sports and as people play fantasy games
or have a daily game of skill they're
engaged in and I hear there's some
bedding going on I'm not personally
aware of any of but I hear the Sun going
on when people have an interest in a
game it makes them more interested in
the game and that's good for us will
they will they be betting via ESPN
portal i will they be playing daily
fantasy on a partnership level through
again we're very engaged in fantasy were
very engaged in daily games you will not
see anybody betting on a USP in portland
what's what's the pool tell me what do
you think is the pool of money out there
and this it's an untapped revenue source
that the owners are dying to get their
hands on you know i do know that the
lottery was five hundred million dollars
the other day and that is a kind of form
of wagering so the pool is vast it's
billions of dollars i actually don't
know the answer that question
specifically but it's obviously a vast
vast pool if time when our comcast goes
through what does that mean for ESPN
we're
we're partners with comcast and we're
partners with time warner and we'll be
good partners with Comcast Time Warner I
don't think it's that profound for us we
pay attention to it and we haven't
publicly commented on it particularly
but I don't have a strong opinion is
that because you've got the winning hand
and no matter who you're partnered with
everybody wants to watch ESPN I think
it's certainly the case that we built a
very valuable aggregation of content and
nobody denies that the ESPN network and
networks are the most valuable content
in the pay television universe and so
yeah that does provide us some comfort
that the those companies however large
they become will want the ESPN content
now what's the next big sports rights
contract you've got your eye on what do
you want to put on ESPN that isn't there
already well you mentioned already the
world cup of hockey man we're very very
excited about that in 16 we got the
european championships in 16 of european
football which we're excited about we're
excited about this NBA deal we're
excited about all of our right steals
it's like children we're we like the law
he loves me he loves the NFL's most
hockey can't get the can't get a sticky
can't get his popular can't push as much
product as Major League Baseball NFL NBA
what's missing well look these are all
popular leagues the NHL is traditionally
a really really strong league in big
markets New York Boston Chicago Detroit
they have a or in the process was
spreading that popularity other parts of
the country I admire what they've done
we would like to be in the NHL we jumped
at this chance to be in the world cup of
hockey because we admire what they're
doing and we want to be their partner